[Music]
hi I'm sitting here at TBS headquarters
with Jim span is that right that's
correct
Jim tell us what your title is I am a
manager of original productions for
standards and practices I worked in
network for many years as you may be
aware 20-some odd years all told and
they have standards and practices at
network my understanding when I moved to
cable was that there's no standards and
practices was that a mistake yes I took
a big pay cut to come to cable with the
understanding that I could pretty much
do whatever I wanted and you're saying
that that was incorrect incorrect okay
what are you talking about are we
talking about just a few restrictions or
many many restrictions I have a book of
reasons
how big a book is it it's a binder how
thick a binder two inches you think two
inches is thick I'd like to ask you some
questions specifics slang terms for the
male genitalia okay okay I'm guessing
it's okay to say penis because it's it's
the anatomical correct word yes for what
that thing is what yeah tell me if these
are acceptable sir dangles manaconda by
an animal yes the one legged pigeon yes
the SuperSoaker why'd you giggle with
that one that's just funny I can say
brass right correct about bazongas yes
Hobbit a hobbit is yes
mahoma hopi winces oompa-loompas the
scoliosis twins that makes no sense why
would you okay that scoliosis is
curvature of the spine
I guess if you've got really big ones in
that scoliosis sexual positions I'm
gonna fire some slang at you for sexual
positions you tell me if they're okay
taking grandma to Applebee's decorating
for Lady cake yes the old Tokyo
sandblaster you ever done the old Tokyo
sandblaster this is very formal
environment
would you mind I see you have couches
and chairs you mind if we get a little
more comfortable sure I'm going to show
you an outfit and I'm wondering if I can
wear this outfit on the show okay do you
mind Brian would you step in please
now did you skin me your formal yes or
no am I allowed to wear this on the show
yes I can wear this you promise
shake hands okay thank you very much you
can go Brian
on that we have you on tape I'm a man of
my word
you're gonna let me wear that I don't
let you wear that gonna we'll have to
keep it very brief as far as but time on
camera how much time would be acceptable
let's test right now Brian could you
come back please I'm trying to determine
how long we can see my butt for would
you step forward and I'm gonna have him
turn and then you tell me when we've
gone long enough okay
turn that's enough
[Applause]
okay so I counted four seconds of my ass
is acceptable four seconds and it's all
did you sign this place for second two
days could we send in the next gentlemen
please this is a underwear fish tank I
would wear this occasionally on the show
do you have a problem with this I'm
gonna have to ask if you can turn around
the Sun this is it submarine I think we
could approve this you could approve
this outfit yes okay I need you to sign
right here mister your name could you
also sign Tokyo sandblaster please okay
I was watching TBS the other night
diehard two came on you guys had dubbed
some of the swear words I questioned the
quality of the dubbing I'm not trying to
be rude but I'd like you to take a look
you guys yeah mr. Falcon
yippie Kay yay mr. Falcon
there's no mr. Falcon in the movie
what's wrong was saying you became a
mother that's not my assistant answers
the phone at work how would you like it
if someone dubbed your voice and put in
things that you didn't say how would you
feel about it you're making these
judgments these are important judgments
that you're making
have you had show business experience
yourself I have what have you done I was
in the 1999 maybe a road trip wait a
minute you were in the movie road trip I
was in the movie road trip the road trip
the road trip where all the dudes go on
a road trip that's correct
what's your part I don't remember yell
is a fraternity sorority party where
they're or you're in a movie buying a
woman and now you're running standards
and practices mr. Falcon you sicken me
[Applause]